hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so the first thing i
want to tell you today guys is that i
got the virus so i was very sick for a
few days i got fever everything i think
it's my brother that gave it to me so
basically my other brother got it my mom
got it but we all feeling good now and
you actually gonna see why this is a
good thing for amc and gme let's get
into it
[Music]
all right guys so should i start we're
gonna see first amc i'm gonna show you
the chart
i'm gonna make different scenarios that
i think will happen now i will explain
to you guys why i believe we need one
more month maybe two more months before
things will start to look better
i'm also gonna discuss with you guys
what levels to watch on the s p 500 on
the spl index to know which scenario we
might be going to first which is
important and i'm gonna give you targets
for let's say june 22 maybe jan 23 and
tomorrow i'm going to show you a video
about what to do with all these options
that are going to expire on the gen 22
maturity because a lot of them
are going to expire worthless i'm afraid
and so they need to be rolled but there
are some things that are good to do some
things that are less good to do so we're
going to discuss that tomorrow so first
let's start with the chart guys i'm
hearing on my discord that you know you
guys give me a lot of bricks i can see
in the amc and jimmy recap i'm not sure
what it means i checked a bit on the
internet i don't find anything bad about
that so i think that it's just related
to the fact that i'm saying for quite
some time that amc and jamie price will
drop
and they did so maybe this is why i'm
bricked and yes guys uh this is the view
i'm having since we broke out on the
downside from this triangle so i'm right
now on amc guys we broke out below 38
and since then i told you guys that you
know you can check the video i did one
month ago i was telling you guys that
that we're gonna have something like
this all right okay this is what i was
saying and this is still what i'm saying
so i'm gonna explain guys listen
carefully i'm gonna give you something
very cool right now
uh how to know i'm i'm basically right
now writing a course so it's gonna be uh
you know a book a pdf and a few hours of
video so it's gonna be mostly about
breakouts but i'm gonna use the other
techniques fibonacci divergences
everything and i'm trying to build up a
big uh like a strong method to know how
actually to know if a breakout is good
to trade and when the market is likely
to continue or on the other hand to
reverse and what i'm gonna be focusing
in that course guys is about volume and
volatility consolidation so i'm gonna
show you here a very good example of how
to use it to know if we are ready to
reverse or not and one more thing guys
for those who are in the
platinum area on discord i advise you to
stay one more month at least for those
who maybe wanted to live at the end of
the month because they're gonna be some
very serious discounts for this course
for platinum members so just
i wanted to tell you guys this right now
okay so let's come back to what i was
saying how to know if the market is
likely to continue to reverse right now
who is in control
guys okay bears and control it's pretty
obvious right since we have this
breakout bears and full control how do
you know if they are still
in a phase where they're going to take
ground or in a phase where actually
things are gonna
be more quiet and
boos might be ready to take back control
you check first the volume so look at
the volumes
so we're gonna analyze just this move
down okay so we can see here
at the beginning
very low volume so each time before you
have a reversal we have very low volume
which means there is balance between
bulls and bears then one camp is taking
control here bears to control volume
we're going higher okay
then
what we want to see right now guys is a
period of low volume just like we had
here okay just like we had basically
each time before any reversal you can
check here guys okay look how low the
volume were at this moment and then
suddenly bam a volume breakout together
with a price action breakout this is the
signal of a reversal but before it
happens the volume must be very low for
quite some time because it's showing
that bears are finally not trying to
take more ground that they are satisfied
with the price
for now what i'm seeing is that the
volume is still increasing guys here
look on this move down the volumes are
increasing we still don't have low
volume okay
so the first indicator which is the
volume is suggesting that we need more
time we need a period of at least maybe
10 15 days of the price action trading
on low volume
the second indicator that is very
important to check is volatility so for
that you can use bollinger bands guys
this is a very good indicator
that allows you to know if uh the market
has consolidated enough and look each
time same thing before reversals we have
this narrowing of the bollinger bands
let me put them in yellow i don't like
them in blue
um
okay
and we have the narrowing of the
bollinger bands before a breakout on low
volume okay i guess so whenever you see
that so how long did it last
here guys it's 10 days okay
and before that even 10 days so it was
like one month and we were talking about
the consolidation that last okay you
know so basically one month for now look
at the bollinger bands they're still
widening right we are not even in the
process of tightening so bears are still
in full control it doesn't mean we will
go lower for sure i'm going to give you
the scenario very soon
but it means that even if you go higher
we're going to get rejected quite
quickly there is a low chance for now
that we have a real upside breakout
unless there is some amazing news which
is always possible
but i think that right now is not the
time for good news is the time for bulls
to heal the wounds and the good news are
going to come later i'm going to come to
that very soon in this video so first
here you can see the widening the
volumes are still quite big
so we are not ready to be in a period
where an upside breakout would be
followed by a strong move up okay first
thing so how long do we need guys it's
visually it's quite difficult to say i
want to do something like this you see
so maybe march and then you know some
something like this we have the earnings
coming here so this could be a catalyzer
on the 3rd of march
so we have some good news about to come
and one more thing like i said guys i
have the kovid my whole family got it uh
once again nothing bad i think you know
it's omicron variant and the good thing
about this parent actually
is that we are sick but we are not
feeling too bad and more and more people
are actually catching it either people
have the vaccine or people uh have the
virus and either way we are very soon
coming at a point where everybody would
either have the vaccine not long ago or
had the virus not long ago so we're
gonna have the collectivity so we're
gonna have the immunity
and this is the reason why i believe
this
uh virus wave is the last wave all right
i can do some eliot wave theory on the
virus we did one two three four five
this is the fifth wave and i believe
this is the last one and that we're
gonna be feeling much better in maybe
you know we need two three months for
this virus to be really i think uh
behind us for now it's it's gonna grow
many many people gonna get sick but not
a lot are gonna die because it's not
that harmful uh as some other variants
uh i'm talking about omnicron that's
what the doctors say so people are going
to go back to cinema they're going to be
very good news about amc we're probably
going to have some very nice increase in
the revenue and look at the price guys
we're right now at 20. so it's cheap
it's really cheap i mean you know even
analysts that say that uh you know amc
was overvalued those guys they have
nothing more to say and apes are still
here ready to buy so the only
worry i have and that's why i have two
scenarios either we go
up from here it's possible but guys we
closed below 21 so we have here
a downside breakout we're gonna after
testing it one two three four times okay
so
this
breakout could be valid so i'm going to
come to this right away but first we
still can have a rebound okay let's be
honest guys amc is the stock where we
saw the most fake outs in 2021 all right
so this could be the first fake out of
202 maybe i hope so but if it's not it's
not going to be bad at all and the
rebound is going to come soon but first
scenario we go higher then i think we
can go to 27
get rejected
okay maybe do something like this then
maybe come back and then okay so this
would be the first scenario once again
guys you need
to check whenever we have low volume low
volatility this would be the signal that
we are ready to reverse this is the most
important thing to
check whenever you want to know if the
market has enough energy is prepared to
really i mean for the bulls to really be
able to shift the trend
so second scenario guys
is uh that we
as you can see guys we have a breakout
below 20. and you guys know that i was
talking about 16 15 in my previous
videos it's possible we go there right
away okay it's possible so this is the
second scenario we go here
maybe we get first some retest of the 21
area then we go here but not for long
okay guys and then we go here and then
same uh outcome at the end and what is
going to tell us
if we drop below 21 or if we first
rebound it's probably going to come from
the global market so once again you guys
heard about the negative beta we have
with the s p 500 that's true whenever uh
we we saw in the past five times and i
did a couple of videos about that that
whenever amc moves strongly higher it
started with a strong move down on the s
p 500 that triggered some margin calls
that's true this is what i
believe is true but the way things
happen
is that first
everything is going down together and
when the s p 500 is reaching some levels
that it hasn't reached for some time
then the margin calls are triggered this
is how i think it's working so let's
analyze quickly the smp 500 you can see
uh so basically i'm talking about this
correction to arrive since uh like for
one one month i'm not sure it's coming
now or maybe in three weeks but
you know it really looks like this
market wants to correct so this is the
spy tracker you can see we have here
market making higher highs uh the
magazine making low high so this is the
divergent this is a sign of weakness
uh we have the rates that are going to
increase and we are right now very close
to the long term
support uh trend line that is here and
we are testing it for the uh third time
right now in uh quite a short period of
time so the more it's tested the weaker
it gets yes remember that so now it's
the third time so maybe it's gonna we're
gonna have a strong reaction of the
bulls on monday i hope that in this case
amc would probably go in the first
scenario 27 then probably rejected but
if the spy drops okay here which is
possible guys okay because omicron for
now even if i think it's pretty good
that it's gonna spread fast and so the
cove virus is gonna be over for good but
for now it's scary right it's scary
people stay home
so
for now it's not going to have
short-term good um consequences on the
market so maybe we're gonna see here a
downside breakout okay if this happens
we're probably gonna do something like
this
a wave then go higher then do a c wave
okay so we're gonna have two three
months of correction on the global
market with maybe the spy going to 420.
so what's gonna happen with amc i think
that what's gonna happen guys is that
this level first here if we drop the spy
is gonna lose two three percent quite
quickly okay doing the a wave before
rebound so he and i think that when
we're gonna go below the recent lows
around 450 this is when the magic margin
calls are going to get triggered all
right because this is what hedge funds
are like saying okay
as long as the spy is above 450 we keep
our positions everywhere and if it gets
there they're going to be surprised and
they're going to face some margin calls
they're going to lose money they're
going to have to cut something and you
know how it's working they're going to
cut what is consuming the more margin
and short positions on stocks like amc
consume a lot of margins so they're
going to get rid of that they're going
gonna buy back amc that would be by the
way at uh probably around 16 17 if this
happens if the global market drops by
three percent amc will probably drop by
10 15
then we're gonna see the margin call
so then we're gonna see here a massive
move up probably maybe 40 i don't know
okay we're gonna come back to the 20
area so the 1617 level is a very nice
level to buy i would personally buy as
much as i can if we get here then we're
going to do the b wave on the global
market and then probably a c wave so
this is probably going to be the reason
why we're going to go here strongly
higher then consolidate we're going to
here have this period of low volatility
of low volume okay guys this is what we
are looking for we're gonna see once
again pay attention to the volume guys
very important for now they are growing
on the downside it's not good it's
bearish whenever we see them
very small with low volatility once
again guys you just add the bollinger
bands and you can check guys you can
check in the past how things happen it's
always like that okay before any
reversal
the bollinger bands get really tight
okay
here for example it was a really nice
situation because they were very tight
we had the upside breakout
okay so this was you know a typical
setup for a strong bullish
move unfortunately we went on the
downside and so
whatever the direction the same
reasoning applies and right now
we're gonna get stuck here i think one
more month i'm gonna show you tomorrow
guys what to do with the calls that you
might be having on the 145 strike i
personally will put a place a very good
strategy i thought about it quite long
today and i came up with something great
i'm gonna post it in the discord of
course as well guys all right so this is
my view two scenarios i don't do global
market drops below 460 amc goes to 16 17
then bam margin calls then we go back to
the 25 30 35 area then we consolidate on
low volume for maybe one more month
so here it's in april may i don't know i
think that's yes this is
unfortunately when we would start to see
all the positive results coming on amc
earnings are here those earnings are
probably not going to be that good by
the way but the only the earnings coming
in september uh 2022 are going to be
probably amazing the revenue are going
to increase people are going to go back
to cinema the coffee is going to be
behind us this is my view and this would
be the time amc would probably break out
strongly those level and go to the 135
level and maybe more now guys jimmy so
the exact same reasoning applies here
guys so you can see guys bollinger bands
they were very tight here we broke out
we got [ __ ] we are we have already
gone through that okay we're not gonna
do the the story again we are right now
in the same situation look the bollinger
bands are widening the volume are
increasing on the downside okay guys
this is not the time to look for
breakouts buying the deep is good but at
the right levels so 115 i told you guys
that we might be going there we went
there i think this is a level when we
can start to buy shares
i think that weighting the 100 or even
the 80 90 level not 80 the 90 level
which is the 61.8 percent fee projection
of the a wave if we form an abc pattern
is a level that would make sense to if
the global market drops so two scenarios
for gamestop as for mc and it's gonna
depend on the global market i believe
either uh the spy close below 460 the
the triple q close below 317 in this
case we're gonna go to 85 then margin
call same thing then we're probably
gonna go here to the stream line
consolidate and then do the strong
breakout and go to the 800 level uh
second scenario the global market holds
so we rebound and we then consolidate
here a little bit longer so i personally
prefer the second scenario so that we
can go for the buyers that are waiting
uh lower where we're going to be able to
average down i would personally be
averaging down all the way down up to 85
and the more buyers we get with us the
stronger we are going to be against the
bears and one more thing i wanted to
tell you guys once again i received a
lot of breaks but i think it's funny
keep giving me those bricks as long as
i'm gonna tell you that i believe we're
gonna go lower but i just wanted to
remind you guys that when you are in war
sometimes it's good to know when to
retreat right if you attack all the time
even if you are not leading the battle
you're just gonna you know
lose your ammunition lose your energy
and it's not the best thing to do in you
know this is the reason why i post
sometimes some recaps when you guys feel
i'm a bit short-term bearish because i
don't want everybody to be buying too
high there's some levels that are good
to buy there are some levels that where
it's better to wait to see actually this
drop in volume this drop in volatility
and to know that bulls are back in
control
so
i'm gonna keep posting whatever i think
is gonna happen and guys this battle is
not done i might be brick today but we
will win and i'm gonna be here to
celebrate this with you guys so i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys